all right scary movie 5 is out of the
way so let's talk about the movie about
the guy who did a little thing like
change the game of baseball 42 so 42 was
the movie about Jackie Robinson 42 is
his number the numbers retired no one
shall wear it again Jackie Robinson was
the first african-american to play major
league baseball which is really
impressive usually in a story like this
like oh it's integration and people have
a problem with that and I did this the
way it was but it's after the first guy
actually did it this was the guy yeah
there's a little bit of friction he runs
into in that evere there we see the
story this is the story of that the guy
they got to play Jackie Robinson does a
really good job he has his young Wesley
Snipes quality to him he does a really
good job at Jackie Robinson you really
get a feeling of Jackie Robinson he was
a good guy he didn't like he
stood up to people he had attitude when
people would come at him with racism and
like that and one of his big
struggles in this movie is that he can't
lose his Harrison Ford the one
who's like I'm gonna get a black guy
into baseball how he sounds at this
point kind of he's gonna make the Kessel
run in less than 12 parsecs
he was like you can't you can't fight
people if you let them win like that
then they win they're not gonna be like
oh he was provoked so be like ah black
dude lost his he needs to be cut
from the team and cut from the sport
entirely he was like channel that beat
them on the field that's where you'll
win so I like seeing that I love it when
people are like alright I'm not gonna
fight you here we're gonna fight on the
field and that field no matter where it
is is going to be my home turf your ass
belongs to me and the supporting cast is
really good Harrison Ford was great at
this movie come out in november/december
there would be chatter about Harrison
Ford possibly getting an Oscar
nomination for his role in this movie I
don't know if it would happen but there
would be talk about it Christopher
Meloni that guy I called the other elias
koteas because he reminds me of elias
koteas he was awesome in this movie he
has a couple of great scenes he has his
one scene in the locker room where he
gives a speech where he's like deal with
this I was like look at koteas but
not koteas alan tudyk sin the movie for
one scene and decision alan tudyk puts
the dick into dick this dude is just
badgering Jackie Robinson and that
Django Unchained kind of vernacular gosh
why but he plays it up everyone in this
movie the supporting cast really does
their job well couple of gripes I did
have in the movie is when the
really gets real you know conflict is
really happening
because there's going to be conflict in
a movie like this no one really loses
their they're always like you're a
redneck piece of trash I don't buy it I
don't buy it someone would just remain
so rated G or PG you want to appeal to
all ages you want families to be able to
watch this movie I think families would
still watch this movie if you let a
character really lose his in a
moment like that where it's like nah I
got to cut this off right here as well
as examples of a moment where harsh
language in a movie really lets you know
that the character has had enough
another thing is they build up the fact
that the baseball field is where Jackie
Robinson's gonna beat these people and
as cool as the baseball scenes were and
you're like yeah dudes good I wish there
was more baseball the movie could have
been a half an hour longer in wish that
half an hour could have been filled with
baseball scenes and the movie would have
been awesome example the last scene in
the movie not gonna spoil it for you but
the last scene of course is gonna be a
baseball scene but it's not a game it's
just one scene in which he is already up
to bat he just has to hit this ball once
doesn't take longer than the movie ends
you're like I wish they had a whole game
for the end of the movie other than a
couple of gripes like that I had a
really good time with the movie the
script goes light in some parts it did
the drama really well it did conflict
really well although I wish the conflict
had some more realistic moments in terms
of language but there are a couple
scenes where you're like this tension is
getting thick and that's good for a
movie like this I would say 42 is a good
movie for families to watch I will say
it's a good time no alcohol required
it's a good story about Jackie
Robinson's life when you come out of
this movie you immediately google his
name just want to know so much more
about Jackie Robinson movie like this
should make you do that first have you
seen 42 and what did you think of it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you